yeah after a while girls don't care i
wouldn't no they didn't care
and i was like i was like [ __ ]
i mean yeah just easy going didn't you
know
but i'd be like i would have i would
ended up dating all of them
you would have yeah i was too nervous
yeah i was terrified never nervous
because i would do this
because i was the kind of guy that i
like i would i'd fall for girls and i
fall hard like i was like a lover boy
like
i want to write you a letter i want to
write you a song you can make statement
i want to make a mixtape for you
like that was kind of i was too nervous
yeah not brilliant to say anything
like literally they like you know i mean
i love them and i love them
is chin going or what's he doing yeah
we're rolling around sometimes yeah like
at cheer practice they'd be undressing
actually like
you weren't doing anything no i was
terrified dude i was but you were
friends with all of them
yeah and i was you know i think yeah
just mainly just because i was scared
i've done plays where everybody had to
get naked because you're in a hurry and
there's nowhere to change and
you're you're kind of transitioning very
you you've had that you don't have that
fat dingling since you were young yeah
but you don't look at
um yeah i know that was aggressive i
think i realized i was working with a
i thought i was you know right but then
i saw porns and i was like
and my girlfriend was like well you
you're that's what you are you're like
i'm matching i was like oh [ __ ] all
right you like it yeah so you
saw the men yeah and some guys have our
monsters yeah no
cal and i were peeing together in the i
know you don't need both our old birds
were out yeah
looks me nine goes we know each other
for 10 years man
our dicks were literally that far and
then that part of heart yeah yeah and
then it was we're playing swords and
then it was real awkward
well you do it with your p stream and it
was real awkward and then i just go yeah
new york next weekend albany next week
huh yeah just
hooking up long drive from that airport
huh yeah that's gonna be fun huh yeah
that's gonna be fun y'all weird though
ask me but i mean
actually it's normal to you guys to me
being an outsider i'm looking at like
yeah
i would never brendan and i are a couple
one two romantic outcasts
what does that feel like we're not mean
you'd be the weirdo because
growing up in cheerleading you didn't
grow up in it you started in high school
uh 15 when i was 15 years old and
there's probably not a lot of guys
no not not at the time i was like around
their locker room
like slapping each other's asses
grabbing towels hitting each other
talking each other in the nuts
look no like you didn't do any rough
house wrestling ah look i have my dick
with the girls nothing oh with the dudes
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we're pushing
against you
i didn't do any like because i did
competitive cheer like it wasn't part of
the school
oh it was like uh outside like a club
yeah
yeah so you didn't have like good
facilities no not until i uh
went to college yeah so but when you
went to uh louisville
when you went there you guys had real
facilities like yeah we had like a real
fast and then when you're in the locker
room what
what would go down nothing besides sex i
mean nothing
but was when did you really when did you
stop having sex with men in like
you get a dick i don't know but where
the majority of the guys on that team
like like the way that i'd say and
cheerleading and competitive
cheerleading
98 okay 80 okay 80.
he said 98 percent what would you say
i would say it's around 80. yeah
question is
straight guys who so so i always say
that my biggest
regret is not joining a [ __ ] dance
becoming a dancer yeah which i clearly
had talent for
i clearly should have been a dancer a
ballet dancer
as a kid is my mother tried to get me
into it yeah and
i didn't and that's my biggest regret
instead i'm trying to get this
is that you didn't become a dancer what
i'm not gonna say there was no girl that
like
so like here's the thing so stupid oh
what was your plan brian be a fly boy
on [ __ ] i wanted i want to be able to
move you wouldn't be a wife you you
could have been a flag
you wanted to be a wild out girl
no no heavy
so make sure your spelling's on correct
jimmy that
yeah hold on no no no no no
f-l-a-g-e-l-l-a-t-e
yeah yeah this is that first word
flag what
that's an algae okay spell it from real
quick all right
maybe f fl a and this is this is what
this is a
guy that waves the people that weigh the
flags can we do that in the
no you don't want to do that i'm saying
there was no girl that ever approached
you
when you were younger that was like hey
brian you look like you got nice moves
yes
because that's how i got into cheer no i
that's the thing is i i
was told by my mother's friend that i
she
said to my mother this kid could be a
great dancer a ballet dancer
my biggest regret there's no one you got
a lot of regrets papa that
can't be it that that maybe maybe maybe
saying my biggest regret is a little bit
dramatic yeah that's so technical
because oh what are you gonna do with
that what do you do with that i just oh
you're you want to be on in living
colored
i know right now next to j.lo
and rosa perez at the end of the day my
biggest regret is you're turning to
ernest saves christmas
all it will slowly turn
yeah there's brian
it's amazing how you have these
references but you're a good one
that's a good one you're right i used to
be slowly turning back into them that's
what happens
he was a big deal in like early 90s he
was when he he died of like lung cancer
right
oh too bad he was [ __ ] funny dude oh
he's so funny
his accent his fate his facial
expressions
were the best doubt my nose
continued to grow yeah that's that
should be your biggest regret what was
the movie we were talking about with
steve martin john candy the other day
playing strange yeah yeah one of the
greatest movies ever you're doing it
with kevin hart
and is it jamie foxx or is it the rock
big big big [ __ ] shoes to film oh
the biggest hey hollywood just write
your own [ __ ] i know don't yeah
regurgitating classes
this is what happens when when there's
all this censorship going around
so they just remake [ __ ] it just it just
unfortunately when politics
gets into art like this i think it
becomes really hard
for arts art by its nature is
irreverent it's supposed to shatter all
the norms it's supposed to be the rebels
yeah right and you need that one person
most of the artists who wrote the great
movies were usually refugees from
eastern europe and they were coming from
communist countries in this
in the 70s that renaissance yeah a lot
of the great directors were
were you know either like eastern
european jews or they were well think
about music
out of music the music that the great
music that came out of the 60s and 70s
was a
was almost a reaction to the repressive
world of the 50s
but like the racism all of it was just
like vietnam
yeah vietnam you had something to fight
against and scream about
and i think that you know now now it's
gonna make it weird like now you've
gotta you've gotta you've gotta toe this
line you've gotta be very careful
because they're gonna dissect everything
you say well even kevin hart he was i
think he's on breakfast club or one of
those shows and he was saying how
he's like you i mean most comics don't
feel safe going on stage now
no he's like it's not good no it kills
you
if you can be canceled for for off color
jokes then what's going on satire is the
whole deal well we're like we're not
going up on stage to say like
the correct thing it doesn't i don't
know you know what i mean because it
because that that's not what comedy is
we have to keep doing it because if we
stop doing it everybody oh you have to
keep doing it
you have to you have to you have to say
go [ __ ] yourself a lot of art is this
a lot of art there's that great picture
of johnny cash doing this [ __ ]
you know that as an artist you should
have you should have some [ __ ] you in
you dude but otherwise
but i still think there are crowds that
[ __ ] with it heavy because last night i
did
jamming the van and like santino and
chrissy d were out there
just they were going hard hell yeah hey
about david lucas's set
oh yeah david luke is hard enough they
love it no
americans make no mistake one of the
cool things about for us is we we
perform for americans people who work
for a living
i think most americans are concerned
with sure well they love equality they
they some they have some maga they have
some wolkville they have whatever it
might be for the most part americans
they want to pay their bills
yeah and and and the other [ __ ] is like
with their own problems yeah that's
and that's yeah that's what i think is
like the average person is dealing with
their own problems so
most of the time people worrying about
gender neutral bathrooms
are people who are in colleges who don't
have any other worries they can sit
around and think about this stuff
it's not the rest of us who are trying
to make a living when you're trying to
construct the life it's [ __ ] hard
yeah it's 24 7 right
raising kids making a relationship work
uh keeping
staying in some shape trying to like
come up with ways different ways to make
money keeping up with the marketplace
that's a [ __ ]
i i don't have time to be like what is
your pronoun i mean i i don't want you
your feelings to be hurt so i'll tell
you what you want but can we get going i
got to get food on the table
yeah no i get it all right kids let's
take a little break from the shenanigans
with the boys
cause 2021 it's here and mental health
is finally a thing
so many people are struggling with that
right now and they feel like they could
use some help and you know what helps
therapy not your friends around the work
place
not your buddies online not instagram
not facebook we're talking about real
professional help
with professional therapists with better
help better help is customized online
therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone if you don't want to
or you can it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and start
communicating with your therapist in
under 48 hours
join the millions of people who are
seeing what therapy is really about
see if it's for you because you are your
greatest asset this podcast is sponsored
by better help
and the final the kids listeners get
temps off their first month at
betterhelp.com
fighter that's better h-e-l-p dot com
fighter
summer is here kids and there's never
been a better time to try a shirt from
on
tuck it they have performance shirts
that wick the sweats when your thick ass
is sweating out there on the golf course
or just at the family barbecue you don't
want to be the sweaty guy let your shirt
wick away that sweat with on tuck it on
ticket shirts are perfect
as we transition back to things we've
been missing like dinner with friends
barbecues we're dining with family
vacations we got you covered
use code fighter for 20 for your first
purchase at ontucket.com that fits for
all shapes and sizes on top
on tuck it offers up to xx xl for your
real thickies
plus they have slim relaxed tall fits
untucked it has 5
85 stores nationwide free returns and
exchanges
use code fighter for 20 off your first
purchase at ontucket.com
yeah no i get it yeah but you guys still
took a piss together and i still haven't
you know
and we crosstalk yeah you cross streams
that bothers you huh
you know how i know you're gay you know
how when i do that bit the gay bit and
if it offends again forever i'm like oh
he's clearly fighting his gayness
yeah cause it's not even like against no
gays it's
like how cool it would be if i was yeah
yeah yeah it's pro gay
then did someone get offended kentucky
oh i wasn't there like come on man
come on man through his hat
i went man you know how come i am i want
jesus christ dude you gotta have been
laughing
it's true but geez someone's struggling
with the truth they always say that guys
who would who would
bash gays like you know who who would
get in groups and beat up gay men and
stuff
they were that the psychology the
psychological profile behind that is
somebody who
hated that in themselves oh i mean that
makes sense that makes sense
you know but i mean there was this dude
i cheered with that literally
in the morning would have like football
players and basketball players coming
out of his room
of course
the junior college there are a lot of
guys that are gay in those sports who
just
can't this yeah i can't tell anybody
about this we've never said anything
right
some of your favorite stars are gay they
just they're like
100 a lot of times they just they don't
care to [ __ ] say it because
they don't want to deal with it i'm
always fascinated with the guys who are
straight
and it's all thing and once in a while
they're like i don't know what happened
you know those are my favorite dudes i
was just experimenting like
what i got a massage
but if it's a girl like we don't say
[ __ ] we don't say things about ladybug
i kissed a girl i get really drunk and
hooked up with a girl like oh that's
cool
and if the rock was like man the other
night had a bunch of tequila and sucked
this guy's dick right
everything stopped everything started oh
well the rock's gay it's like
well no i'm not dude i just got tipsy
and that's well
you know it's you know most gay dudes
will say those dudes
aren't gay well that do like like if
it's like a straight dude
that's just having a night with a dude
they don't they don't claim they don't
claim them
to be gay they don't oh they don't no
well but uh
don't and i've heard like everybody say
that you have to ask your best friend
but it
doesn't their biggest thing is they want
to turn straight guys gay right isn't
that like the big thing in the community
i don't think they no they don't want to
turn them gay they just
are attracted to straight guys my buddy
because it's like it's like a challenge
jimmy
jimmy told me a story about he's in
theater he's
he's they're doing a play in there on
like they're in a regional theater thing
yeah this guy loved him and he was so
gay and and uh he had long eyelashes and
curly hair and
he had this adorable little put it all
out and uh
my buddies my jimmy's like me he's just
he's a dude he's a dude he's
hilarious he's so funny and uh longest
stories in the world
yeah he's sleeping he's sleeping they're
all sleeping in this room without no
money you know
he just feels he keeps walking up to
this his leg is being rubbed and stuff
and he's like he's actually
he's like he's rubbing his hair
and he just sees roger and roger with
his eyelashes like that
not just a little troll a little bamboo
rod he's got
both his hands like this pointing up at
him like this
they're both on his thighs like this and
he's looking at him like this and
jimmy's got a piece and he's naked and
give a [ __ ]
and he's like he goes can i suck your
[ __ ] and jimmy goes like this jimmy's so
nice jimmy goes
ah sweetie
oh sweetie i would but she got a little
beer
he took his face and just stood away and
he goes
goes back to sleep oh sweet the [ __ ]
head pushed
mature again got a little beard you got
a little beard
now are you enlisted in the military at
57.
you have a wife i'll explain what you
have extra from full metal jackets yeah
that's cool
i'll explain easy original cast i went
in to get a little trim you went to a
barber yeah i just wanted a little
barber a stylist no the same guy i go to
all the time he does a great job
typically
great job it doesn't look bad all of a
sudden today he goes he takes
i go he goes you want you want you want
to just neat on the sides i don't know
what that means neat on the sides in the
bottom
you'll be real specifically i'm like
okay i guess i don't know i don't
[ __ ] know i'm like this
huh yeah whatever
that's weird i've never seen him do what
the [ __ ]
well i guess we're going short and then
i had him and then he wanted to cut
just here and he had it [ __ ] like
and he goes what do you think i go
my face is long enough i don't want to
make it long
that [ __ ] up yeah so then he took it
down well tiger got his first haircut
out of barb
barbara i used to go to but it's like uh
it's all mexican barber it looks like
you're straight and [ __ ]
the one you sent me to yeah yeah tiger
went there i wasn't there no i was on
the road this is like a few weeks ago
so his mom took him there and i go make
sure you got to be real clear with him
they don't speak english so speak
spanish to him
let him know that he you want a small
ball tape or fade not high she's like i
got it i got it
they sent me a picture i was like what
did a nazi give him
dude full-blown knot i sent you a
picture yeah he was in the pool
i made his hair like to the side yeah
and then you know he had those
he was just full-blown knots like what
that's that's that's not what you're
[ __ ] what
yeah he went back yesterday different
guys right like never go to that guy
again don't get it you gotta be you
gotta be super detailed with barbers
it's about time
pictures are you from picking you up
yeah i'm like this dude
yeah this also old brother oh bry's face
is when
when you're in those lights oh they're
gonna get you you're you're like man i'm
getting
[ __ ] old i see pictures of myself
five years ago when you oh the lights
dude it accelerates and then on top of
that i'm losing my hair i'm not on
propecia because i'm too lazy to get the
pills i gotta i gotta [ __ ]
take a picture of my head and so you do
just just uh or him
uh bronco job or something like that
is that [ __ ] legit i mean i don't i
don't know oh yeah you don't have to
never mind looking for a hair thinner
yeah you got thick hair yeah super thick
thick thick hair thick body
uh papa shop comes in town tomorrow oh
really staying where there is
don't stop talking about cooking when
are we going for 4 50 on the old bench
i don't know i've talked to mark last
march on friday
you're crazy mark's gonna fill in for
you on friday when you're in albany new
york all right chris yeah albany guys
hey
albany huh seriously everybody in albany
that's listening go to albany oh i
talked to the people at the ice house
this morning
oh you did i was like what i was like
hey la's back open you know because i've
done no shows on purpose
no shows no james nothing no oh well the
the bus family owns the ice house now so
they put all this money in the ice house
to redo everything like they're making
it really dope but
because of kova they couldn't get
permits so that now they've just got
their permits so it's not going to open
up to later in the year
but they're running shows out of ha-has
that's a hot cafe yeah
i like that i don't know the weekend
jack and they're great
for real like that's a real jack junior
jack and that's where joe coy
and kevin hart go it's great yeah and
it's a great club and they're great
people yeah that's a family you
everybody should support that club yeah
awesome july 16th through 17th it's a
great
you should do it it's a great place for
people to start off if you do it i'll
come by maybe i'll maybe i'll
feature for you we'll see all right
let's grow the hair out
throw my hair out of the hair really we
gotta have that you can't have it you
can't have a short like that
now come on
yeah jack just hit me up about doing it
and i was like
i'm on on the road that never happened
philadelphia
philadelphia helium i'm doing a sunday
show helium i didn't even know i signed
up for that 25th 26th 27th i was like
you normally don't do something have you
done sunday i never do sundays
never but i don't mind doing it i don't
work on the lord's day yeah
that i like traveling back on sundays me
too it's just easy
monday's monday's less crowded nothing's
more depressed than the sunday show
and the the only time i've done a
sunday's it was some special weekend
like i forget what it was three day
holiday yeah
and justin talked me you know my agent
talked me into it
and he said no you had to in this when
san jose wednesday he's like i'm telling
you sunday's gonna be big man blah blah
am i cool well the problem is that
sunday
i'm in norcal san francisco 49ers nfc
championship game
was at seven my show was at seven
nightmare
stuff you can't control nightmare no no
can't control it can't control that at
all
but damn i know the week before i was
praying they would lose but
but some i mean traveling back on a
sunday is the best
yeah i mean mondays yeah sunday monday
you don't want to do that
i don't work sundays no you're [ __ ]
philly philly is all right i like philly
it's my one of the other places man
if it's a club you see what's going on
in san francisco you've seen what's
happening in san francisco
where where dudes now are just literally
walking in
big guys they send a big guy in there
they walk in with a huge garbage bag
and they just take 999 worth of stuff
from a walgreens
and they just the guy comes in with a
bike and they're like they're like you
can't do this
it's like these pharmacists and he
doesn't even look at them he's got a
mask on and just [ __ ] bumps out of
the way and just rides out
so this is happening every day so
walgreens they're all closing down
it's all they just yeah one of the yeah
oh because
oh cause the cops don't come because the
cops can't enforce it because
it's not it's actually not against the
law you you'll have a story you gotta
miss him that's a gift you get a message
but i missed me they're still against
the law and then you get you don't get
put in jail
you get processed yeah they keep doing
it
because how many cops how many times can
the cop come by the time they come it's
done
so how many times can you try calling a
cop and having them come come
there's only so many they can do and
it's organized they have one dude after
another doing it
so the most logical thing is to shut
down walgreens it's being done by
organized crime
it's being cartels are literally having
people with their stands their mom and
pop stands
they're setting people up for that in
front of restaurants because it's a
sanctuary city so they don't you don't
need a permit to sell [ __ ]
unless you have a [ __ ] you're paying
rent
so hey hey san francisco is at least our
massacre off
what's that mask off the mascot that's
good i went to starbucks
we all went in there together we're the
only ones without math though people are
still wearing men it's amazing to me
it's very oh yeah yeah
very strange right yeah i'm not walking
in with a mask no [ __ ] off get the [ __ ]
out of them back they do
suck this they said we don't have to
wear them why [ __ ] you why you wearing
it
i think people are always going to wear
them for i think society's changed
it's weird i i feel like we're literally
the only state i'm i'm telling you every
time we [ __ ] travel
like as soon as we walk out in houston
they have a no mass mandate
yeah houston the mall you didn't go with
the mall no there's a lot of people with
mascot on the mall
really oh listen i don't give a [ __ ]
well
let me tell you appleton wisconsin
didn't have them on no
not at all not even i don't even know
because you know like a certain place
that their
the employees will still have it on yeah
appleton their employees did it
but i if you're a starbucks they make
the employees wearing but if those
employees are vaccined why are they
wearing them
i don't know i like how if you're not
vaccinating your stuff to wear a mess oh
yeah
prove it yeah what do you do well gavin
newsom says
you're going to have to have some kind
of a vaccination
uh verification we don't listen to him
anymore no one listens like
anyone yeah you're out bubba you think
so yeah
i mean is he going to get is he going to
no i don't think so since he opened
things up not being retired [ __ ] yeah
who
who are you gonna vote for caitlyn
jenner yeah exactly you know what i'm
saying
that that guy with those terrible
commercials with the bear have you seen
that
no they call him the bear they call him
you haven't seen this the guy run
against them the commercials on
on tv go ahead and bring that it's him
with a bear and he's like
you need to fight newsom the handsome
newsome you're going to need a beast and
it's him next to this
poor bear that they rented for the
commercial oh it's been so expensive is
it like a bear like he's it's a grizzly
bear
that's him right there no yeah and he
and even when he goes to all these
things he brings the bear
oh oh oh wait brian what and this whole
thing is
beauty versus the beast ew what and i've
never heard of the guy so i don't think
he's gonna
now i'll give it new sims a handsome
he's your hands he's handsome
evil good hair look at this six foot
four two everybody's oh you you
oh he's six four yeah he would he would
be in president if he didn't [ __ ]
himself a remarkable success look at him
california's falling off a cliff high
taxes unaffordable costs
even elon musk left
management i'm sorry so are you from the
90s
are you are you from the 90s look at
this yeah oh he's all like
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah the beauty meet the
nicest smartest beast in california
john cox the nicest smartest beast in
america what
it looks like a spoof commercial like
it's yeah i thought it was fake it looks
like
[ __ ] he came up he's the kind of guy
who says this is the way we're going to
do it and people are like
he's like don't want to hear it that's
what it sounds like have you ever heard
of that guy
no but also that's a bad caitlyn jenner
gets all the
press oh like as far as she [ __ ]
herself because
she went she said she's against
transgenders in sports and then got so
much backlash and she's like all right
now i'll transgender cool in sports so
then
damn people just can't like that oh yeah
paul oh
[ __ ] oh yeah come on you're staying
here come on
with putin right now [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] they get face to face different
game in there hey never game
hey you know i was just bullshitting
with you man you know what's up
you know you don't beat the [ __ ] out of
it
when they're when they're competing for
the same job like commodore has gone bad
on biden
bad anyway you know and then uh
she accused him of being racist oh and
and a sexual assault
yeah and then now she's like what's up i
believe that woman but now we're cool
we're friends
now she went to venezuela and they
referred to her as the president
yeah really yeah so that's cool was it
venezuela she went to
yeah i don't know she didn't go to the
border she went to bed i think she went
to
guatemala yeah yeah i think it was
guatemala you've been to guadalajara
hasn't been on the border
yeah and nor has she been to europe i
believe right no well it's here so when
they go
they go you're in guatemala why don't
you go to the border where there's real
issues we can do
and she goes i mean i haven't been to
europe
yeah and the guy was like yeah you right
it's like well no we don't
love today we don't share a border with
europe you [ __ ] just keep it keep on her
man yeah
well then she was one of the people that
you know said decriminalize the border
so i guess just let everybody in take
take the front off your
your house talk to tim kennedy about the
board i just had him on
talk to tim kennedy on the board crazy
right he'd keep you up at night really
talk to tim kennedy about that
it's just i can't he didn't want me to
talk about it it is terrifying yeah well
i talked to two border control agents
who were like you have no idea how bad
it is tim k
is down there you know people dying in
the desert and stuff like really really
kids yeah and man the stories
i told him like dude please don't share
those stories with me it's like as a
father i don't share those stories
i know it's heartbreaking it's
heartbreaking and then before
way before you know our guys would go
down there
and we'd fight you know cartel members
their wife beaters or fat mexicans
whatever they're not very good at
firearms and our supposed forces just
light them up tim goes well now
the chinese sent their people down
because we spent so many resources they
want to [ __ ] america
so their special forces trains the
cartel so they're just as good as us
they have all the
same equipment they're all trained just
like us they've been training
for years he's like so now it's special
force for special forces
it's the nightmare ooh before just our
a team versus their d team and they
would light them the [ __ ] up now it's
different
different game it's terrifying you talk
to someone who's actually dealing with
it he's like oh dude he's like the news
doesn't cover
five percent of what's going on wow damn
it'll break your heart
[ __ ] amen yeah stress you out yeah
stressed yeah
yep yep speaking of heartbreaking means
we got to start training
i'm going to start training oh yeah i've
had my heart broken had it broken
had it broken had it taken out i had it
stomped on and then they poured salt on
your college college goal sure college
and high school high school
yeah college high school and by the way
when i was in my 30s
there was a young lady i loved very much
who was uh got into drugs tried to save
her didn't work
the the yeah i've had my uh math i've
had my share of
of heartbreak oh is math christian any
anything new
new on the dating front now things are
opening back up
oh yeah do you you have what's up um i
like i had a friend come she from rhode
island that moved out here i've been
hanging out with her a little bit
uh i've been hanging out with different
people like from tinder like not nothing
like seriously you make out with any of
them
what he's a cute kid man yeah you get
like
you have a makeup looking guy girl i
usually try and like do more than that
but yeah
yeah you haven't had three girls you
never had a problem getting women right
no not really is it easier now that uh
california is back open
we're open open i mean i haven't really
been on it since we've been open open
there was one girl tuesday yeah
so unless last night you went wild
i wish but nah i feel like it will be a
lot easier
uh now that california's open because i
mean
not that many people are gonna care
there was like during the pandemic
tender like
was like oh you can do these virtual
dates instead of meet in person i was
like i'm not
really how about you leave it up to me
tinder yeah
yeah it's it's dumb are you are you
looking for are you looking for love or
just to
date um honestly right now i'm not like
looking for anything
serious what finds you when it finds you
dude yeah you're not looking for it till
you don't go looking for you're not
working putting up no dude i'm
twenty-two i'm twenty-two
murphy eddie murphy's sketch when he was
buckwheat
paris deep breath what's going on with
you
my dating life yeah i mean i just moved
here i'm not really
looking for anything okay i don't know
you don't do anything but
um i did meet a guy at a party who was
talking about how tinder has changed the
game because he was kind of bringing up
to me he asked me the same question and
i was like
you know i'm not really looking for
anything not really about the tinder
life he was like no no no because of
kovid
like before it was kind of the hook up
platform and he's like well now people
are finding their soul mates on tinder
oh yeah he was trying to sell me on it
i'm like are you like partnering with
tinder or something he's an influencer
or whatever
that makes sense though because if you
can't like go see and hook up with
people you're just [ __ ]
facetiming he was named dropping left
and right he's like oh so-and-so they
just they just got married and i was
like okay i don't know what i'm talking
about but yeah he was trying to name
drop left and right yeah
it's primarily like nights hinge is the
one where you find the love yeah
i don't know i thought all like online
dating platforms were about hookups like
that's at least
60 percent of people meet online now
yeah at least the college experience all
my friends who are on tinder
are not looking for love they're like ah
just looking forward to hook up
that's lit yeah so i've left and right
just trying to trying to smash you know
it's how
i wouldn't want to meet a like uh
significant like a girlfriend or like i
wouldn't want to meet
get a girlfriend from tinder i'd want to
meet them in person if anything tinder
like all those apps i would rather just
use
for the hookup you know what i mean like
you never know you might hook up with a
girl and she's dope but yeah keep
hearing you find love like sixty percent
that's it it's 21. dude i mean i
i i did so so if you meet a girl on
instagram would you look it's the same
[ __ ] that's a that's uh
yeah you are the same [ __ ] a dm how's dm
different than the tinder
yeah when i get bored of tinder what i
do is i go to my local like
i go to where people tag like the
location i live in i just go to the
recent post and i'll
just go to their instagram if they're
pretty enough
scotland it's literally like instagram
tinder no i don't know
it sounds a lot like ted bundy
no he's doing his thing he's got he's
navigating he's figuring it out yeah
right yeah it'll open up more
opportunities yeah but you but you have
gone on dates
oh yeah yeah damn look at you short king
there was actually when i was back home
i
you were right about that you could meet
a girl when you said you can meet a girl
on dinner and hang out with her
i did meet a girl that i hung out with a
handful of times
from tinder and then it just fell apart
well i came out here
oh this is back home yeah so i was like
ah
see ya you're going to find love this
year this year
damn right for me tinder's been like or
tinder and social media platforms are
just a bunch of weirdos
like super creepy ass i feel like for
girls if i had a daughter i would not
want to entertain
all in my dms it's like you look they
have like it's like sketch too like
one follower they're following one
person it changes people who are
actually looking for relationships no
farmers only is where
you're gonna love your folks at pharmacy
yeah also farmers only code word for
whites only let's be real oh is that
right yeah
there's farmers only farmer's only a big
one
there's black farmers yeah some
well biden had a that relief bill for
black farmers
you know what i'm saying well like if
they if they had an app called
nba players only called ryan
yeah like he was like nba players only
it's like like
if i'm a white dude i'm not jumping on
this yeah right right yeah
oh my god i'm looking for white guys i'm
going to nba apps
for ryan too you can have what look you
you don't have to be a celebrity to be
well you have to get you have to get
clear right yeah i'm still on the wait
list
i have buddies on right yeah you gotta
submit like your tax returns
yeah there's a lot of famous people you
gotta be able to vote no no i didn't say
fat
did i say fat you did famous but the bad
i've been on the wait list for like a
year yeah kind of upset about i'm
[ __ ] up words this day as i [ __ ]
stay away from that flag no you keep
saying it and it's not even a real thing
so let's just stay away from it no it
wasn't for you
he looked it up no i know it's a funny
oh it's a fungus
i think the word you're looking for is
uh color guard that's what popped up
instead of urban dictionary
like the girls who have the flags during
the cheer stuff
well i'm sorry if i used the word flag
it too many times also i've had a
daughter and
her goal is to be a cheerleader and i
see her out there just waving the
[ __ ] flower
well that's how i feel about the crew
the the the coxswain
who's who what's called the coxswain
what is this you got the guy who yells
come on let's do it you gotta get it
you wrote like i i'd be like oh my god
yeah
he's like damn i'm on the road to him
like [ __ ] yeah dude you're doing like
that i'm gonna get to the olympics he's
like no i'm the guy
that i'm the coxswain you got this come
on that's good
um show me a coxswain embarrassing he
just sits on the back and he has the
microphone
uh there's the cheerleaders and then
people who didn't get on the true team
but wanted to be like on the field where
the spirit team and they were like
they had different versions of a
cheerleading outfit that wasn't as good
and they were just a little more a
little more hip right like
hours was not oh a cox ours is like
bless you if you didn't get on that
thing that's [ __ ] you go there
[ __ ] swing so the purpose is they just
yell they motivate you yeah like
row row 100 meters 50 meters
has there ever been enough take your
pants off swain coxswain whatever
they're called what'd you say has there
ever been an olympic toxin or not oh
yeah they have
oh yeah they have you really i guess
they keep everybody in line but
you can go [ __ ] yourself yeah i don't
need that kind of motivation i'm not
doing that [ __ ] in a million
of like the the motivational coaches i
remember
the thing is rowing coxswain yeah well
no this guy in high school i never did
one of the rowers i didn't know him he's
[ __ ] big and quiet and weird
and he's working out and in the gym as
he's doing the
he's yelling she's yelling come on you
got it i'm like yeah
this is so embarrassing yeah you're
ready it's so embarrassing
they have they have a rowing team at
harvard don't they look at how small
there's this
big big cal we have a we have a rowing
team
syracuse syracuse yeah i think they're
pretty good i think they made it to um
ncaa tournament those roads are a big
scandinavian looking
so what is the object they're just going
my size and just [ __ ] huge
meaty yeah whoosh studs and then they
get done like ah [ __ ] we should
they i don't know the what
rowing like does like are they like
racing
yes yes it's a hellish sport i mean as
far as exhausting but you know how your
big ass got in the rower machine the
other day yeah now imagine
i won racial no well yeah they're like
six foot six
they're like they're my size but even
bigger and just thin
shredded and just [ __ ] terrible oh
you got to be a big dude
yeah well because you need the the lanes
[Laughter]
no
that's what i mean though i don't care
yeah you know
you you among what is it six or twelve
you know whatever it is one two
maybe five is there any black dudes on
those teams seven eight guys prominently
white sport
it is yeah and i hope black guys aren't
like what's this all about
you guys yeah not as ours man let us
have this stay out of rowing staff
hockey
got
yeah oh what's this all about what's
this
all about no no no no no this is stupid
it's stupid dude
it's so so [ __ ] stupid you got to be
so in in in sync with each other like
what
yeah i guess it's like teamwork i it's
pretty cool though it's not anything
it's not my favorite you think it's cool
hell yeah i also finished you would go
watch the rolling
uh [ __ ] like harvard in the finals or
something like that if my son was into
i'd get super
no just a regular one not not at harvard
in the finals i'm talking about just
regular
like they're going down like venus
canals or some [ __ ] no i would look like
oh that's cool you keep on keeping huh
yeah any anything i'm not gonna get a
fly kind
any sport i feel that is that specific
and
just one movement for me is is uh
i don't know i i just can't see working
that hard out it's not interesting to me
a lot of hard work though of course but
yeah at that at that one
but what else is like that shot put
discus there are certain things that
seem to be
one very specific movement and it's fine
it's all good but
i don't know like when you're playing a
ball sport it requires so much more like
were you pretty active in high school
like did you did you participate in a
lot
wrestling oh just wrestling dancing no
wrestling you didn't get to track i was
actually a drag
i could throw a javelin far from my size
but did you
you didn't do just football in high
school you did or were you like in the
student council uh no i thought he said
oh no i never did any of that no you did
that
no any of that student council stuff not
any of that
that's right no i don't do any of that
stuff that's a lie didn't you
didn't get great grades either no i was
into wrestling
girls and my friends and then you know
yeah
you know guys i was young being with
other dudes yeah no but i mean as far as
i think was football and lacrosse and
then if i didn't get a scholarship like
footballs you can go to the military
that was the case getting the care you
need to stay healthy shouldn't be hard
these days man or expensive everyone
should be able to afford their
medications
check out good rx they help me find
lowest
lowest prices on my prescriptions every
time with goodrx you can instantly
compare prices for your prescription at
every pharmacy in your hood save up to
eighty percent
eighty percent good rx is free and easy
to use many times can often be
cheaper than using your insurance copay
or medicare with good rx you can find
discounts for your prescriptions at over
70
000 pharmacies cvs kroger walgreens rite
aid vons walmart
and much much more good rx is the number
one most downloaded medical app and
millions of americans use goodrx to get
affordable healthcare every
month start saving up to 80 on your
prescriptions today
go to goodrx.com fighter that's good
rx.com
fighter goodrx.com slash fighter good rx
is not insurance but can
be used instead of insurance in 2020
good rx users receive an average savings
of 70
of retail prices never thought about the
military
waking up too early i did welcome for
your freedom but i not me but you know
what i'm saying
yeah you were gonna do that what were
you gonna what were you gonna try to do
uh i'm not sure my dad was in the navy
and then my uh grandpa and uncle were
marines
and my other grandpa was in the army i
come from a military family are you too
big for
like no not even close you got
flashlights maybe seals are my no that i
don't i'm still running for some 40.
be cool uh what'd you say about him wait
what do you say yeah flat feet
i thought you had flat feet no no that's
that was malik yeah we had this
conversation before
now you could no navy seals are my size
a lot of some of them yeah yeah
they're not you're tall but you know i
talked to tim about it i believe
he was like you'd be just a normal dude
there you're not you're not like
like a giant there at all jesus oh [ __ ]
well tim's [ __ ] thick
[ __ ] short but wide monster monster
[ __ ] monster yeah green berets
they're all they're all
it's well i mean my friend my friend who
was a ranger said that when he would
jump out of a plane he was
i remember looking at him he's about
225. just big
you know and a weapons expert and i was
just looking at his hands black belt and
jiu jitsu and i was like
he was a ranger and i said what are you
waiting he goes 225.
i said when i was in afghanistan i put
on a marine's full outfit like
it's so heavy 80-90 pounds i was like oh
well i i don't i literally don't have
the strength to
carry the [ __ ] around all day my back
would break and he said yeah when i
would jump out of a plane
i weighed 400 pounds oh yeah i mean he
had he had
pounds of gear on him radio and all that
it's like you forget how much was it did
he weigh without all that
225 so he's carrying almost his body
weight
like something so it really helps when
you're really strong it does it helps
when you
you know especially on the fifth or
sixth or so we all keep rubbing all the
time
and then a lot of sports special forces
guys are on uh
supplements enhancers you would have to
be well why wouldn't you
yeah i mean why wouldn't you want to be
at peak performance because otherwise
you
break down yeah but also like let's say
you got a
a [ __ ] special force guy who's like
you know
mid 30s late you know late 30s
yeah he's going to get on he's a little
help but he has all the knowledge and
can
[ __ ] you know do this it just needs a
little i do know sealed team guys who
are
like 180. like i know there are sure
oh yeah but it i would imagine it would
help when you're carrying the 180 is a
good size
if depending on how tall you are your
athleticism it's all about
you know also how how it's also i think
a lot of it is
the training is designed so that a lot
of guys
don't make it not just because of the
cold sometimes guys just can't deal with
the majority don't make it but a lot of
guys get like
weird things like a stress fracture in
their shin or they break their foot
yeah and the reason for that is that
they want to see the guys that don't
have those liabilities yes your
liabilities are like that's a fun that's
a thing
like that's no different than the you
know major league sports yeah
they're looking at everything the guys
who don't have all those injuries and
stuff yeah
whatever it is whatever it is about your
body you're not able to do that for
you know uh eight weeks without getting
injured you know some people are just
more sturdy
physically yeah balanced differently you
know
need less sleep they're saying don't get
cold diseases they're saying now it's a
problem the navy seals have gotten so
much fame and attention that they're
having a problem getting navy seals
because they don't like all that
attention right like now navy seal you
know
it's like they're so big yeah that david
goggins was a navy seal right yeah
mm-hmm he's savage
he's he's insane i don't think so
pictures he'd be posting and [ __ ]
he never did any tours i don't believe
something but he was like the
outlier even amongst them like they
would have him run them through
drills and he was a bastard even with
them oh yeah
damn yeah like he'd break even those
guys
he's a monster you see him [ __ ]
running like a million thousand [ __ ]
yeah he does like a thousand pull-ups
i've had seal guys like tim kennedy
talked about this too like
a large thing about being a great
operator isn't just
strength and being able to shoot
straight it's also knowing who to shoot
and who not to shoot in split second
time
too oh no goggins all uh fire
12 navy seals yeah in 2005 during
operation red wings in afghanistan 12
navy seals were killed
um my apologies have you seen
have you seen lone survivor i don't know
mark barber that's i don't know that he
was actually operationally
trained he says he knew all i don't
believe he was actually in i don't know
always
says to iraq the seal team five served
as the training instructor for the other
seals until on five during operation
12 navy seals were killed and more were
injured in brutal fighting goggins
personally knew every seal involved in
the mistake he was deployed but didn't
necessarily mean he wasn't commenting
yeah yeah well i'm not saying anything i
just said i heard somebody i heard
another shield talking about it
i don't i don't know i don't know i
don't care a little bit though i love
listening to him talk i don't know i
don't care
it sounds like somebody hating on me
yeah we never saw no no i didn't say
that
i know that's why he's throwing this he
got famous now i have no idea what
happens
i have no idea if he saw combat i just
heard somebody else talk about it
you regurgitate it i don't know somebody
was in what were you going to say
christian um lone ranger oh lone
survivor
uh the mark robert movie that's based on
uh operation red wing
ah yeah yeah it was tough good old mark
wahlberg
so i wonder if goggins is might be like
someone played gogging than that maybe i
don't know
i i think is grillo's in that movie at
me or no
grill uh zero dark 30. yeah that's right
i thought there was another one he was
in too
i could be wrong he's a bunch of [ __ ] i
think every steel that i know has
been that none of them really like to
talk about any of it because i think so
that one is that thing where you go
oh i saw combat that's great and a lot
of them saw a lot of their friends saw
comet didn't make it back
and it had nothing to do with whether or
not they were it's just i don't know
anyone who's seen that
type of warfare who kind of talks about
talking and it's also
code like they don't like that you know
the navy seal who supposedly killed
uh osama wrote the book dude
that's like rule number one of navy
seals but you wouldn't talk about it
you did a whole book on it he doesn't
well he doesn't get the money now
i'm pretty sure the the navy got the
money for that book
i don't know man i i i think a large
person you're not allowed to capitalize
off yeah
transitioning out of the seals is always
probably a challenge like any time
you're you're
in this intense world it's no different
than professional sports though it's
like you've dedicated your life to this
one
thing you had one mission to become the
best you can be and then those guys get
done just like anything you got to
somehow parlay into something else and
yeah goggins and godzilla's done a great
job with that so it's john
tim dylan did the best tim kennedy tim
kenny sorry
yeah i was like tim dylan yeah tim
dillon was also crushing it
not a navy seal tim kennedy's tim
kennedy to me is so astonishing because
by all accounts my top five favorite
people by all accounts
he's this high level operator god knows
what he did
but also he's [ __ ] without a doubt
one of the best
185 pound mixed martial artist to ever
step in the octagon
at one point that [ __ ] fought
all comers yeah i don't care about any
of that he's also a monstrous big deal
he's not though those guys are monsters
those guys are
no but wait a minute he had two jobs
yeah i yeah yeah
kind of but he did that but he's a
monster of a dad like he's such that's
what i mean but the guy does everything
right he's he's just naming like another
starting his own school in austin
he has his own school his own foundation
he's like making
real money now i just need to be an
operator and also be performing that
high
at such a high level in ufc's seems like
i don't know i don't know how he did it
i really don't the toughest guy in the
world in some ways maybe the toughest
guy
in some ways i don't i don't know smart
guy too
entertaining had his own tv show in
history he's got a good sense of humor
it's hilarious yeah yeah he's the best
monster monster you never rolled with
them or trained with them
we've done workouts together we've never
trained together no
never oh you roll with guys like out of
your weight class
oh yeah yeah what do you think i only
roll with heavyweights oh that [ __ ] i
don't know
problem with heavyweights really good
ones yeah hard to find training partners
right
mm-hmm damn he had the biggest guys come
in these
[ __ ] dudes he'd be like that guy's
six nine what the [ __ ] we'd have to pay
him and should have sucked
oh really and then because it just you
said there wasn't a lot of heavy weights
like this
so i'd always go with a lot of 205 which
i preferred because they're more
talented usually
faster got it oh okay that makes sense
oh smaller guys so it wasn't like
the smaller guy's always more talented
okay but they're trying to knock your
head off
that was what's crazy about some of that
stuff like his his coach uh his coach
offered this six nine he goes i'll give
you a thousand dollars if you can knock
him out
what so now brennan that guy needed the
money and you guys didn't even warm up i
was like
yeah what's going on here you i remember
exactly what happened you did this weird
you did a stretch where you went like
that you did a lunge and you did this
and you did this
and then you did this and then
he went the guy went boom and tried to
hook you so hard and you just went
you ducked just like this and it went
thing
it kind of like gave you a haircut and
then you double leg them and you guys
cry it was so [ __ ] nuts it was
on on like on on that black house trying
to knock each other the [ __ ] out
that was silly and i remember when he
came in the room i looked at him and i
went like this my face
changed i went he's the biggest guy i've
ever seen in my life and he's got
cauliflower ears
he's six nine yeah six eight six six but
like professional
mma professional kickboxer high level
and and and
brandon's getting his his things wrote
and he looked at me and he goes you want
to be a fighter huh
and i went different kids it just
it just sounds so stressful it's an
awful way to make it so [ __ ] every
time you go exactly
[ __ ] knock a guy out your heart every
tuesday
for real but like so like when you guys
are like sparring and all that stuff
like you're going
like as if you're like doing the fight
especially when you're close to the
fight
so you have to go that hard mm-hmm yeah
typically
yeah if you guys are that hard you're
gonna be in for a big surprise in a real
fight
yeah because you're in a once they lock
their cage the guy's trying to kill
you and he's and he's 260 pounds so
[ __ ] intense
yes the one that once intense jump the
one crazy thing is i had my hand on the
cage
watching and they locked up
and crashed into my hand
500 pounds
it was a silent scream like you got
electrocuted
and my fingers i was like [ __ ] and then
they they bounced off that cage and went
over and landed both on their [ __ ]
heads and your neck was [ __ ] up
forever after that
oh [ __ ] he almost broke his neck like he
landed on his neck i was like
might be dead and then that [ __ ] me up
with a trash brown fight because the
exact same thing happened remember
ah because you had to take him down yeah
and then him
he sprawled in his hip that gave you the
concussion oh yeah
yeah yeah i [ __ ] my neck that's a good
time it's a great way to make a living
no so much fun man that's a tough game
no so much fun you don't know about that
guy and
if he doesn't if he loses then he goes
down the rankings and he doesn't eat
it's a great time us three sitting here
is a great but the
biggest the biggest thing i remember the
biggest thing you gotta remember is
heavyweights
heavyweights nobody ever talks about is
like if you're 170
140 155 pounds you can afford to make
mistakes you can take shots you can slip
you it's a different way of fighting
right
if you're fighting matt matrione or
you're fighting guys like that who can
who who
are professional football players that
can crack who are 270 pounds
and fast as [ __ ] you if you get hit with
a jab by accident you can get knocked
out
so you can't make mistakes when they're
throwing bones like that with giant guys
knocked out uh derrick lewis by
sprawling he's yeah
that's right so he like shot in and he
just sprawled his hips so everything
you're doing everything you're doing the
consideration is much bigger it's all
like a head heavyweight your head's the
same size
our heads are roughly the same size you
might have his head a little mine's
smaller
it's you had a smaller heavyweight head
for a heavyweight kind of a problem
yeah that's a problem yeah you want to
be the ortiz got that [ __ ] but it
doesn't matter
even that he you're still getting
knocked the [ __ ] out if you're fighting
a dude his size it's 270. but i was
small i'm not 270.
oh i'm sorry okay 260. i mean i'm 255.
now all right
255. so when i was fighting i was too
like 235.
that's you were probably a little bigger
than that bubba i promise you didn't
check my waynes i was 35
38 heaviest i ever was was 42. okay
i was fighting guys that's 60 75 20
pound weight difference no one wants to
talk about it
that's exactly right when you bring up
who who is that who's on steroids
watch let me just say johnson bring up
lavar johnson test it hot too
you still fought him well we weighed in
and dana you know dana was talking i go
you know he's on steroids correct
and danny goes what i go he's got so we
had to look at that [ __ ]
i told dan i said you know he's gonna
finish fifth in the olympia after this
oh [ __ ] what happened to his stomach
he got stabbed oh part of the game my
dad has that same skill
but now look at look at his size yeah he
does he knocked out everybody
uh-huh i mean he would just be how tall
was he
about six four yeah yeah is he black
yeah yeah
how how much he weighs he's in prison 65
to everybody to there we are together
prison oops well let me see
who's he in prison for he's bigger he's
in prison now for a domestic violence
he's a lot bigger than you are look at
how young you are holy i know look at
you
i thought that was aaron hernandez for a
second oh he did
240 240. and you just took him down and
held him down there
i took him down like 14 times i beat the
shot of him wasn't he
was that a decision he like come on dog
let's get up and fight yeah
you did not like fighting let's get up
and bang bro i'm like why don't you
learn jiu jitsu
oh he said that to you while you guys
were in the fight yeah i kept taking him
down
and then i was so worried because my
uncle pax is the first fight he went to
he uh yeah that was a big ufc on fox 5
fight
i was on fox but um i was worried about
him
because um he was part of like the
mongols gang like the biker gang and my
uncle pax
that was the first fight he went to and
after the fight we all went back to the
fires hotel
so we're all at the bar you know i'm
drinking whisk or whatever and
levar comes with all his biker gangs and
i tell my brother i hit him i go hey
they're here and all my team's like ah
[ __ ] dude we don't want no problems yeah
and they were all monk i didn't know
these are horrible yeah
i did not then lavar came up and they
were all great
all the biker guys were cool like man
you helped our boy with his grappling
man
yeah they were great yeah no doubt all
yeah how do you have problems with those
guys well you don't you don't go get
don't go
walking around like you know you're
looking at my girl
just be cool cool i don't even have good
eyesight [ __ ] wouldn't you want to be
cool
you know just don't be stupid yeah they
don't [ __ ]
up innocent people you don't get another
you don't get in the mongols by going i
would sign this right here yeah
all right jim what do you got for us
what shirt is that chin
i know it looks dope thank you is it a
band t-shirt no it's a
believe it or not i actually got a
sponsor my little youtube channel got a
sponsorship
people yeah what is it
into the am like am pm so i guess it's
like i don't know if it's clubbing or
not but
oh it's like yeah that's more that to me
that's like uh
like this was like a rehab shirt right
exactly that's why i liked it
yeah it's like i overdosed and died in
the bottle or that's like your prison
you know
oh yeah yeah you're a prisoner you're
struggling with a drug but then he's
floating in space
so he's dead most likely oh yeah you see
it
like he's falling asleep there's a
skeleton in the bottle
it's all that cradle it's
versus kratom you started you started
you know kratom's the counter
yeah kratom's natural creature is all
natural yeah this is a
that's like algebra pharmaceutical
hard [ __ ] yeah you still on a
gillian milligrams of adderall christian
uh no no uh
i take like three a week right now like
i don't take that much
more how long have you been taking that
off for adhd oh yeah
for like since you were a kid like in
freshman year in high school but when i
take adderall it gives me more energy i
talk more so why would you want
it if you have adhd pentax to focus your
mind
now for me if i take 10 milligrams it's
cocaine
it's a soft version of meth if you look
at the same molecules yeah your base
staying small it's amphetamines
i mainly take it before i go to the gym
because i can like lift forever if i do
oh like because i'm just so in tune with
it like if i
like take an adderall like while i'm
doing something or before i do something
and it kicks in while i'm doing it i
will be focused on that speed for hours
speed speed one hundred percent yeah
control it though you're good
i took it once trying to do homework and
i was up online i took too much and i
was like
suited yeah you take like i was i had
workouts the next morning or like
something for softball it was like
the end of the fall so it was like
didn't really matter no i don't
i was are you done playing or used to
have eligibility left
i have eligibility left okay i want to
ask you the question though yeah don't
ask me that
yeah yeah i know the question because i
was big in baseball
i don't know what's up it's focus yeah
it like helps you focus
i guess i've heard i've talked to a
baseball player who was like oh yeah i
took it and i'm focused but
hell yeah it's funny he's like you can
see the ball better it's great and then
i've had
some people i knew take it be like
i can't i can't do it i hear too much
well um
yeah because i choose like if like
baseball that's like drug of choice oh
bry took
10 milligrams um and i have not worried
about the ticker huh that bothers me
when you start doing drugs well
i i don't do it anymore because i had
two shows that night and i was like
speed through every [ __ ] joke i can't
do this i'm too sensitive to it i can't
i can't do i did it you know what the
truth is can't even really drink wine
anymore
i'm not gonna do it again i can do all
of it no you have to drink wine anymore
no i might just
i might go super monk style do vegan go
vegan nope no way i'll eat meat
but i might i might how flat would your
chest get if you went vegan
yeah dude with that top of your chest it
wouldn't be bulbous like it is now i
ain't vegan a lot look at my chest
yeah thick kid yeah i'm gonna um
i'm gonna up my workouts what do you got
i feel like you and i like drugs i've
tried i don't know sure yeah you like it
you like it
i don't yeah you like it you're the kind
of guy
you're the kind of guy who will go hmm
let's see
and then i'm ready to go give me an
entire cup and a big and then i'm going
to bench
415 pounds and then and then you might
even go i have to bench
and i'm just saying you might you might
go uh
what is this syringe
uh-huh you might do that you might do
that and then you might
is that anaphor you know what if i was
my skin's not tight enough
if i was on sauce or anything i'd be way
bigger
yeah he's a good size i mean yeah you
don't look like you're i mean you see me
doing cardio yeah
yeah look what yeah right what you don't
want to get bigger right you've said
over and over you hate being your size
yeah look at me trying to get smaller
brian's gone brian thinks everybody's
right
i'm not saying you're built like i said
anything i didn't build like a fortune i
haven't even asked a question
but you you shifted your whole body
because you turned it did you thought
chappelle was unreal
you thought i was i'm just asking i
wanted to ask one question i'm getting
attacked
all right i did trt like three years ago
i've talked about this on rogan and my
face
you never told me that i blew up you
never told me that you keep a lot of
things maybe two maybe two years no he
you know no you you
did tell him that yeah i told you that i
tried it yeah it keeps me in the dark
my face blew i got moon face now you get
some my face blew the [ __ ] right now
i was sweating right now you're walking
natural
yeah you're not running any gear no we
think i'm on
anavar i don't know why he's smiling
he didn't have a flashlight on you the
bell sees me every
answer me a question without smiling
okay let me ask you a question bring
your hands down get vulnerable
i am no no you guys are you're bracing
yourself
look me in the eye you can't even do it
you're getting into it
have i dabbled in someone's dog can
daddy not try some stuff are you i'm not
in the
ufc you're amongst friends and nobody's
copying the comedy store is not going to
test
i'm not saying they are nobody's looking
you're all netting i got a boy who works
for you he goes he goes hey man
between us if i were to send you a test
would you pass it i and i just responded
like
don't send the test
i whatever you're doing i think it looks
good to be completely honest with you so
i'm i appreciate he just does bcaas
protein i'm sure he does that's all it
is if i ask him the questions
he could never am i sweating
a daily my goal is 20 pounds by the end
of september i know by the time i do the
denver show i'm gonna lose 20 pounds
you're always safe with me so whatever
you're doing i don't care
you can always talk to me so do you
believe i'm not on it yeah you're
definitely not
done did you see him bench 315 that's a
lot of weight
did you i have my suspicions
freaks me out no i know and you don't
like caffeine i don't
yeah no you're you're not you're you're
naughty oh nettie bcaa is protein shakes
yeah i don't think you take that no i
don't
terrified i'm terrified of everything
you do do you do bcaas
you do a little um a little there it's
in protein drinks so
you do protein yeah you're going deep
with this building right now yeah
bro he goes in the gym he started doing
the stuff you've wanted to for a long
time you've wanted to just kind of
push it a little bit yeah well i think
now i've just accepted that um
you know you've told me this forever
just accept my size yeah just be funny
that's what i'm doing i'm a huge fan and
i used to be super uh self-conscious of
posting like workout videos
on my instagram because i'm like uh
stand up guys really don't do
working out and it's like oh they can
suck my dick right i've never
i've never had understood why he would
be i was sure he'd be at [ __ ] parties
and he would stand with his legs like
far apart so he was
the size of everybody and then we're at
this training party and he goes like
this he looks at me like hey
i'm enormous i was like yeah but
you know that's that body dysmorphia
right yeah yeah but be
bigger and stronger than everybody with
your ears it's awesome no i feel you on
that you just feel like
dudes like it and girls yeah yeah what's
the problem i mean i have no problem
i've never understood it yeah i've never
understood it just be big as [ __ ] i even
asked gianni i was like okay i get this
video of me dad left in 600 should we
post it he's like what what what the
[ __ ] yes
best i'm like i'm worried it's not going
to work in 415 like it's
like nothing i'm the strongest guy in
comedy name somebody stronger
well you are the strongest guy you can
also beat up everybody rogan's really
strong
look at me look at me like now like
you're talking about
like standard like bench dumbbell like
he's
don't get me wrong he's definitely up
there it doesn't matter what no
no no he can't bench what do you want
you don't have to throw it heavy like
that because i said
he is strong look at him professional
athlete
and then comedian professional athlete
football player
heavyweight in the ufc so it's a
different bone structure
and and also like so it's like
somebody said somebody said to me how
would rogan do against shop
now you could ask rogue and he'll tell
you and what in jiu jitsu or
fighting and but people ask us
i don't think that's no it's not a good
question it's not a good question it's a
bad question
it's a bad question but there are people
that will say stuff like that the people
you know guy said to me he goes bro if
you really [ __ ]
went out shop like if you really tried
the other day they said that because
they saw my senior citizen that senior
how funny was that dude
who did this he's hilarious he's scroll
down this isn't my page
you posted on yours yeah i post on mine
there's this page
this was genius and i look like an old
[ __ ] oh this one okay oh it's so funny
assault no it wasn't chase that didn't
caught on camera inside a nurse oh this
is
something
live the video is very disturbing again
this video was hard to watch
the person who set up the phone to take
the video is the suspect himself
in the 75 year old man 75 you [ __ ]
and the young man can be overheard
telling his victim something about
staying out of his bed
on a senior citizen caught on campus how
great is that he's
so funny he's breaking my little arm
very disturbed
very disturbing yeah it's hilarious gosh
amazing all right jim what do you got
all right
here we are so a news anchor freezes
live
on air after basically having kind of a
petty fight
there's one news reporter that
introduces the next person who's going
to do a segment
and she doesn't like the way she's
brought up so she starts getting petty
and telling her
no that's not how you introduce me this
is how you do it and the
news anchor says hey we're live and they
just freeze hey
before you play us jen did you ever see
that that i freaked
not a famous comic like low level comic
but he for some reason
for some reason he was in trouble he was
on trial and you know they're reading
the stuff and they go and uh he he
actually works as a part-time host
uh on a live tour with some big comic
there he actually works at host he
stands because sir
sir feature in the future
oh boy oh boy man oh boy but that does
that not explain comics
i should not show you i saw a certain
feature in the judge like
sure okay i saw you i saw two pretty
well known actors fighting
about who was going to get an interest
first for the red carpet i saw them with
their agents getting into a major
problem
and i was like can't be friends with
either one of you or anybody here you
guys are all
[ __ ] weird all right let me see your
chance
a champion natick to fight in ukraine
this coming saturday and for more on
this
jessica christian and jessica good
evening
when we speak about sports we are here
in coca-cola we'll be fighting in so no
you're not going to do that you're just
going to greet me and then you say take
jessica real life
do you want to read a book
look at her
then it goes off but i don't get what
she she
what was she upset about it's not like
she introduced her like in a negative
life
i think she didn't like that she started
speaking again like when she says like
oh i'm gonna throw it over to jessica
then she takes over but the original
news anchor continued to talk
oh she was all oh she's like this is my
time
well the epic thing is that that guy uh
he's a freestylist we did this on king
singing
freestyles on the morning show have you
seen this no and uh
she goes do you want to do a free stuff
for us she goes sure and he starts
trying and then he just freezes
and he goes is this live she was like
[ __ ]
and she goes do you want to read your
book
years ago this is the top one this is
the best video of all time
shout outs theo von for introducing me
to this
hold up spoken word
is a rapper turned spoken
he's all so scared doing well
so tell me why the change from rapping
to spoken word
because it's basically the same thing
you know i deal with words
for the bible it says in the bible
first there was word in the book of
genesis
and so we live our lives based on that
book
which is the bible so uh you're going to
do a spoken word for us now right
right and uh tell us what we're about to
hear
it's just a freestyle okay i'm just
gonna think it up freestyle
well let me sit back go ahead marshall
okay
no i can't
years ago they tried to years ago to try
to
put me in it
this is live
[Music]
i don't know if you can find it but
apparently when they did tang remember
tang
the drink and they gave it to the
astronauts and they were like we're
gonna
watch them drink this tang and they was
it was like a commercial for it but they
didn't tell them that it was at the guy
goes
this stuff tastes fun
like sir you're live yeah and it just
[ __ ] up
i wonder if you could find that man 11
years ago
yeah but i think this one this i'll try
it i think they did it
obama asked astronauts if they still
drink tang up there because that's what
they were drinking it was such [ __ ]
it was like just literally sugar
oh this is from 1966
yeah i don't think it's the actual
commercial yeah
apparently in things you do in space
they drank tang
they mixed it like this in a zero g
pouch because all over
yeah all right never mind tank
good for you huh
they're looking for the one where the
astronauts actually told the truth and
didn't like it
it was live on tv goddamn 1983 tang
commercial wake your kid up with that
sugar drink
i know all right [ __ ] all right what a
sketch in
right here so we've talked about this
before
uh where charles barkley has made fun of
women in san antonio called the little
dogs bulldogs
yeah but then the the left came after
him saying that you can't
refer to women like that anymore so so
many people because he's done this joke
over and over again it's kind of like an
inside joke within people who work with
him
and so he's done it over the years he's
actually doubled down on it
and it's gotten to a point where he's
gotten so much backlash from people
that tnt actually told him you cannot
make that joke anymore
he calls the women bulldogs or just he
says uh women from san antonio are
bulldogs
and this is a 13-minute compilation of
him making that joke over and over
throughout the years
the temperature in game one in san
antonio it was
[Music]
san antonio by the way haven't spent
time there there are some big
people i love santa oh really it's nice
i'd rather move to san antonio than
austin yeah in a lot of ways
yeah all right
okay so harley quinn has a animated
series that's r-rated
and on this they explore a lot of more
darker storylines and dc comics
especially is well known for being
very dark where they have like sex in it
they have murder
so this is normal but uh the cartoon was
told that they had to pull a scene from
it where batman is giving
uh catwoman head that's because they
said that heroes don't do that i
think they do and they do
i disagree with that and now there's a
bunch of batman memes going around
saying that heroes don't
give head is there anything better than
that if you've ever someone's going down
or
heroes don't do that you do you are you
you're not squeamish about that are you
no no thank you thank you
i know guys who are like i don't do that
i'm like you don't do that oh okay
that's weird dj khaled doesn't do it
no it's great stuff it's great
it's very important for
but yeah they're basically saying from
marketing standpoint we can't do this
because we're trying to sell action
figures
which makes sense well just don't have
your kids watch the
dark version of this exactly that's all
you gotta do most people
don't let their kids watch that though
yeah watch what the darker version of
the
animated series i don't know harley
quinn i'm such nice harley quinn
is the joker's girlfriend she's a oh
okay she's good she cares about played
by that badass margot robbie margot
oh that's joker's girlfriend yeah marco
and robbie's got something to say oh my
god
from uh what did they call that show
that movie suicide squad
suicide squad yeah she also had her own
movie she's so gorgeous
and that talent i've seen in person
she's stupid she's as talented as she is
gorgeous
well she played sharon tate well she's
wealth wall street's super bad but she
also played sharon tatum with pawn time
yeah didn't she play
some crazy character where like the
woman was like a murderer
i'm tripping never mind cheerio do you
think of jennifer's body
you think of megan fox no well she was
dressed up she didn't look
like the same the skater movie no i
don't know not the ice skater nothing oh
tanya yeah is that a tanya is that is
that it she looked completely different
yeah like she looked like like just done
up horribly
she looked like tanya harden no she was
a great night tonya
amazing she taught you how i was here
tanya harding wishy looked like her
yeah no she looks great johnny harden's
a bulldog
oh i'm thinking charlie's there oh oh
yeah monster yesterday that's a true
story about a serial killer and brian's
friend sorry brian's friend was the
director patty jenkins yeah
all right what else you got jen so the
tokyo olympics
are going out of their way to supply a
bunch of condoms to people
and i guess this happens every single
time the olympics goes on because
they're trying to uh
promote uh advocacy for hiv and aids
and what they're doing now because of
covid is saying
we're going to give out all these
condoms to you guys because that's what
we usually do
however we don't want any of you guys
hooking up at the olympic village
they have to say that legally yeah but
there's
so much it's [ __ ] greatest athletes
in the world all coming together
making a super bowl yeah are they
getting down at the olympics like
that village it's just there's nothing
to do
everybody's doing i don't know what you
say
the gymnast no when they broke her she
landed that trick and broke her she was
very young i don't know she was
but there's a like if you get the you
get the water polo players together the
teams you get the
[ __ ] you get the track athletes
the the italian pole vaulters with the
[ __ ]
this is basketball players there's a lot
of [ __ ] you're getting look at that look
up italian pole vaulters for a second
if you please i mean i guess let's do
that no the girls i'm saying
women yeah go ahead and
let's look at this women yeah yeah go
ahead and
look at and yeah there's one thing i'll
never understand it's like
how to [ __ ] do that there she is
[Music]
but there's all kinds of stuff that goes
on look at that look please bring
well that's the same girl okay so it's
the same one this is like the most
famous one right yeah
i think she's engaged she should she was
famous forever
she was on uh bodybuilding.com for years
maxim
but there's a lot of athletes that are
just cheeked up
that sport terrifies me yeah pole
vaulting yeah weird sport
i don't think we can be our sizes we see
the us but the soccer team some of them
are baddies
on that team yeah yeah but then you also
got the men's basketball team too that's
what i mean
but they don't stay in the village they
stay like the last last olympics they
stayed on a giant yacht together
because they're all millionaires yeah
hmm
oh there you go alice morgan's really
just the face of the team
yeah either way wait isn't uh
the guy dating one of the j.j watt
isn't his girlfriend on that team uh uh
she's a soccer player yeah but she she's
for houston
uh professional league i don't know if
she's on the national team oh i thought
she was
she's a battery though you might be
right though chicago red stars
national she was she was a part of the
united states under 17 under 20 under 23
senior nationals oh no she was on the
team oh she was okay yeah that's what it
came
up she's a baddie oh they're married
oh yeah must got married she looks like
she's she's got a samoan name
oh hi we can't even kid anything the
first name huh
yeah but her last name too born in ohio
oh she's from oh utah
yep that's a white girlfriend
hello you can name a kid anything you
don't have a huge samoan population
though yeah they do
they do that i'm gonna make oh no her
father named after kellia beach the
island of kauai
because he's a white guy who loves
hawaii i'm not giving him yet huh
let me see where mom is from yeah mama's
timon
is she no no no her mom is oh let me
look white
there's some white stuff going on there
yeah i mean she looks pretty white to me
so i'm going to go ahead and say
that she looks super white she's legally
she's a badass play at north carolina
let's play that's like playing football
at alabama
they're really good oh yeah the women's
north carolina team is really good
athlete athlete what have you got jen
this is gavin newsom announcing that
california's open again
and then i guess there's a few things
that went wrong here he called optimus
prime optimum
because they're at universal studios
it's a brian kellen mistake yeah
she's older yeah i'll just play the
thing it's not that long called
optimum it's optimus prime yeah today is
a day to celebrate
a day and there's like music that goes
off the wrong times
you know confetti progressive uh
strangers loved ones family members
the silence people are always really
aware i love when they put music behind
it
yes the one that waka flocka has
concerts and we've got a lot of work to
do because i said this and i'll close
we're not just coming back we're going
to come back more focused on inclusion
more focused on equity and we're going
to come back
roaring back california is
open again california has turned the
pace
let us
and let's bring those minions up and my
personal negotiator
optim optima he panicked
helen thank all of you i'll stand by why
did they have that universal
i don't know that sucks it sucks because
i'm a governor sometimes you have to do
that
[ __ ] look at the guy taking a selfie you
gotta do all that [ __ ]
someone say something on a count of
three say cheese jeez
[ __ ] this is so awkward he's so over it
and there's nobody there there's there's
zero there that's the most anticlimactic
[ __ ]
yeah until we meet again
protect the planet protect each other
autobots
you guys are really roaring back there
you gotta do that [ __ ] as a governor and
a president you have to do that those
little [ __ ] things
this is cool juneteenth i didn't really
know what juneteenth meant but it's
like the anniversary or the tulsa well
the slaves were afraid
emancipation of slavery yeah so it's
becoming an actual holiday civil war
it's going to become an actual holiday
now where people get days off if you
work in the
i guess for the government yeah or
federal 19th right yeah
i think that's a good holiday yeah
however this guy
ron johnson says he doesn't want that to
happen because the amount of
money people are going to lose from
people not working that day
it's one more day off for columbus day
but he backtrack and now he's for it
okay great question
so there's that uh don't forget mine oh
yeah so teo fema lopez is supposed to
box i think this is what this weekend or
next weekend this weekend sir oh this
weekend but he has a cover villa
on trailer so the but they postpone it
to august
august 14th yeah and then uh chris paul
who's the star of the sun you got covert
too
he's out damn and this is
these days yeah oh that guy has my shirt
on
someone said this was me now when you
get the
when you have the vaccine can you still
test positive for kovic yes
you can they say it's rare but it
happens yeah
but that's if the vaccine doesn't take
then i don't know i don't know what the
thing is see there's too much
information that just is out there i
don't know let me see this guy okay in
my shirt unfortunately me and my uncle
pulling up to adrian kickback with party
tricks like
what's up no don't do it don't do it i
know please don't do a backflip
[ __ ] oh
[Applause]
as soon as he set up i was like he's not
landed that that's how you get hurt
i thought he was going through he
thought he was going
really had the confidence
that's how you get hurt when's the other
one good or is it more i'll just show
you it's a quick one
so this is a tick tock that went viral
it's a stingray yeah they look friendly
[Music]
that's cool the only problem is uh
like a marine expert says it's basically
suffocating to death
it's not oh that's cute
hopefully they toss them back in the
water i know these are nostrils they
look like eyes and little mouth but yeah
those are nice yeah i hope he threw it
back in that water yeah
it's all tickled you know
i'll see you this weekend um glad you
are you want me uh
uh albany funny bones june 18th 19th
philadelphia pa helium if you like
betting on combat sports roughhouse
fridays
july 9th that's the first episode me and
tom mccormick
my goal is to talk to experts and give
you the best odds
on betting on stacked cards whether it's
boxing
mma and uh and then i've got
conspiracy social club which is starting
on rockfin exclusively
me and sam tripley the great sam tripoli
big and hungry podcast listeners we're
doing
questions from young men so uh uh
send your video submissions into um big
and hungry podcast
gmail.com let's go boom
boom um
pittsburgh july 22nd 24th i have la
dates coming up i'll be at hahas i think
it's
july 16th through the 17th i have more
stuff popping up but right now
uh tickets i think haha go on sale today
that's in la
and then uh pittsburgh july 22nd 24th
that's it
chappelle and uh i'm not doing anything
until july
15th through the 17th uh to victor yeah
yeah
maryland boobies magooby's joke house
and then august 26th bray improv get
those tickets
uh brendan might stop by and say what's
up yeah maybe
if you want to take that drive that is a
bee
yeah that's a beast especially in rush
hour we'll figure it out
all right kids love you yeah